[Música]
Hoy es el tercer día de la conferencia
del clima de la ONU en Egipto la Cope 27
y aunque todavía quedan poco menos de
dos semanas de las negociaciones
climáticas más importantes del mundo hoy
finaliza la Cumbre de los líderes en
ella y durante estos dos días han dado
sus discursos casi 100 de los jefes de
estado y de gobierno invitados pero no
solamente los políticos tienen voz desde
la sociedad civil también están
surgiendo iniciativas para revertir el
daño que le hemos causado al planeta
María Clara calle una de nuestras
enviadas especiales a la cop 27 conversó
con la directora de un proyecto que
reúne información acerca de la
restauración y la conservación de los
bosques María Clara cuéntenos Con quién
está usted
ella es directora de un proyecto que se
llama redstore una plataforma en la que
decenas de organizaciones y de personas
colaboran para intercambiar datos sobre
la reforestación en todo el mundo claro
bienvenida a France 24 y explícanos en
qué consiste restaure Muchísimas gracias
Pues como dijiste una historia es una
plataforma digital que está uniendo
todos los proyectos de conservación y
restauración alrededor del mundo
Entonces lo que nosotros ofrecemos son
datos ecológicos datos de monitoreo que
traen tanto contexto como transparencia
a estos proyectos y luego permite un
intercambio de experiencias de fondos de
colaboración entre proyectos para
acelerar el trabajo y el impacto
es la plataforma más grande dedicada
precisamente a esto a conectar datos
Cuál es la importancia de compartir
información y si nos puedes contar
acerca de algunos proyectos de
restauración que Claro que sí pues es
todos sabemos que no tenemos mucho
tiempo para llegar a las metas de París
la naturaleza es una parte
increíblemente importante de esto
sabemos que la naturaleza la
reforestación puede secuestrar 30% del
carbono que sea acumulado en la
atmósfera Entonces es increíblemente
importante que actuamos rápido Eso
significa no hacer los mismos errores
ves tras vez tras vez lo que tenemos que
hacer es asegurar que cuando estamos
Aprendiendo a través de proyectos esos
aprendizajes se comparten y que vamos
acelerando el impacto a través de ese
intercambio
Y por último qué tan importante es este
Resort y sobre todo Cómo se creó pues se
creó Resort a través de un proyecto
científico la idea originalmente fue dar
datos a las personas que realmente
pueden hacer algo con esos datos porque
muchas veces los datos científicos se
quedan en las universidades y no se usan
entonces la idea fue a ver hay que
difundir pero rápidamente nos dimos
cuenta que en realidad los datos son
solo el primer paso es la experiencia de
los proyectos que es súper importante
compartir y queremos inspirar a través
de eso Entonces un ejemplo en Costa Rica
acabamos de de trabajar con el gobierno
de Costa Rica para mapear y publicar
todos los proyectos de pagos por
servicios ambientales que ellos tienen a
través del país entonces cada lugar
donde un agricultor está recibiendo
dinero por la protección de su terreno
lo estamos mapeando y eso crea un de
inspiración no y un modelo que hay que
replicar a través del mundo Clara Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
France 24 y ustedes sigan conectados a
nuestra señal con directo con 27 yo los
dejo por ahora con la conexión en Bogotá
y nosotros Seguimos aquí en Egipto
le agradecemos a una de nuestras
enviadas especiales a la cop 27 María
Clara calle por su reporte y a ustedes
Les agradecemos por su atención
Recuerden que pueden Seguir nuestra
cobertura permanente de esta Cumbre
climática aquí en nuestra cadena en
France 24 en nuestras redes sociales y
en Francia 24.com sigan con nosotros
[Música]